le premier étage du château de cheverny
c'est là que nous rencontrons notre
maître horloger devant une pendule louis
xiv
qu'est ce que vous êtes en forme et là
je viens de remettre une pendule en
place c'est une pendule que je viens de
réparer elle s'était arrêtée
vingt ans qu'elle n'avait pas été
réparée par mes soins donc voilà on m'a
téléphoné jeu là je viens de l'art met
en boîte
claude est donc un habitué des lieux un
spécialiste qui connaît par coeur les
pendules de cheverny
ben là je les démonter complètement gelé
revu entièrement c'est à dire tous les
points d'usure tout ce qui était à
revoir au bout de vingt ans ce sont des
choses qui qui s'usent ça tourne quand
même pendant vingt ans sans s'arrêter
ici tout est remonté de sa marche tous
les jours au château tout revu tout est
refait dans les règles de l'art voilà ce
jour là glaude échanges avec le
régisseur du château
l'occasion de lui rappeler la démarche à
suivre pour le passage à l'heure d'hiver
je vais t'expliquer le principe enfin tu
tu vas comprendre un de toute façon au
changement d'heure là il faut reculer
alors c'est toujours un problème quand
il faut reculer
souvent les gens y pensent pouvoir
reculer les aiguilles non il faut pas
reculer les aiguilles il faut arrêter le
balancier et attendent qu'une heure
passée au bout d'une heure tu remets la
pendule en d'accord c'est beaucoup plus
simple renault va donc gérer seul les
traits horloge du site pas de souci le
régisseur du château est habituée ces
mots l'uefa toussaint et le remontage
bon j'ai une certaine pratique des
horloges fait ce qu'on leur montre
clairement une fois par semaine tous les
mercredis
ils ont besoin de régularité c'est le
mercredi matin
la cérémonie du remontage des horloges
des horloges d'un autre siècle réglé à
la minute près pour donner la bonne
heure